Heroes.
It's an old fashioned notion,
but the world can still use them.
Ready?
Whatever it takes.
We destroyed that house,
but it's not over.
My work is inevitable.
There will always be more
to finish That.
This is just the beginning.
She tore a hole in space.
There's a different reality
leading into ours.
What are you prepared to do?
I'm resentful.
Your powers only make me stronger
so you can't be matched.
Can't be controlled.
I'm asking
for one last fight.
you cannot protect your
people
You can stand tall
without standing alone.
You're here
Monica
You got to fly
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Marvel just released another trailer for The Marvels
There's a bunch of X-Men teasers, a bunch of teasers
for another version of Captain Marvel,
like a whole other universe in this.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I'll be posting my review of the movie on Wednesday
when they let us do that
then my Post-Credits scene video should be up on Friday
in the My full breakdown Easter eggs this weekend,
so be sure to go see the movie when you get a chance
some of you probably spotted the X-Men teaser
during this trailer.
But the other thing is the director of the movie need
the constant legit said Did she actually pitched Marvel
on directing an X-Men movie with Storm and Cyclops
like a team movie with the two of them.
so just goes to show you how much X-Men stuff
kind of went into the making of this movie.
I really like Scott Summers and storm together.
They're dynamic as like fighting over
who should be the head of the X-Men
has always been really fun for me to read.
Like in the Chris Claremont run.
So I think some sort of like Scott Storm team up
movie would be fun.
that doesn't mean that Cyclops and Storm
are going to appear in this movie.
They just means that before
she directed the Marvel's movie,
she had wanted to make a Cyclops Storm team up movie.
For the most part, they lean really heavily
on the whole Avengers of it all.
Like Iron Man, Captain America, Thor,
a bunch of Avengers endgame footage
at the beginning here with Nick Fury's voiceover
from the original Avengers movie.
When he's talking about heroes old fashioned notion,
that was part of his big rally speech
during the first Avengers movie because
he's trying to call on New Avengers in this movie.
Like we're starting to see them reference
the new version of The Avengers team
slowly in the background we're starting
to get pretty close to Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty.
We need a new version of the Avengers team
to actually form,
so they had to actually start referencing
in some of these movies, there's way more voiceover
dialog from the Avengers movies and there's two
from all the different Avengers characters.
when Captain Marvel is talking about them,
it's like we destroyed Thanos, but it's not over.
That's actually new voiceover dialog,
probably from the Marvel's movie.
when he's talking about
there will always be more to finish my work.
That was actually in one of the last trailers.
It's like unused voiceover
dialog that was supposed to be in Avengers Endgame,
kind of like a deleted scene from that movie.
But the way they're using his scene in this trailer
is to reference Dar Ben using her Ms..
Marvel bangle like the other bangle
that she's been looking for this whole time.
in that's meant to dovetail with Monica Rambeau
talking about
opening a whole to another universe,
like there's another universe bleeding into Ares.
that gets into the whole idea of the incursions
that we're going to see go down during this movie.
the sort of two references during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness, where Reed Richards
was basically explained to Doctor Strange
incursions are when two different universes collide,
destroying one or both of them at the same time.
in the whole idea is in the lead up to Avengers
six secret wars, we're going to see
all the remaining universes
start to collide with each other,
like it's slowly happening in the background now,
with different characters being responsible for them.
Like Doctor Strange caused his own incursion
that they reference at the end of that movie
Deadpool
three is meant to be kind of like Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe.
He's going to probably cause a bunch of incursions
during that literally and metaphorically
destroying the Marvel Universe. Oops.
but so far, we haven't really seen too much of that
in the Marvel movies so far.
We saw a little teaser for during Ant-Man,
The WASP Quantumania,
where you saw Kang the Conqueror history in him,
destroying different timelines.
that also combines the idea of the incursions
with the Kang Multiverse War, which we'll see culminate
during Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
did a Loki season two deleted scene video recently too
when the season started because they revealed
a bunch of deleted storylines in scenes
that feature another version of the Kang Multiverse War
that we would have gotten during Loki season two.
but they decided to save that for Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty because they wanted to do
an Avengers level version of that.
In the version that we would have seen during
Loki Season two was way smaller with way fewer
characters like with your Avengers characters,
when this we're talking about Da Ben using her
bangle, making universes collide with these
sort of like opening holes through different universes.
They show one of her ships in front of the sun.
There's later footage of Captain Marvel
flying through the sun, going full binary.
I think that's what we're seeing in the movie.
She'll actually go full binary.
there's actually a funny story behind the creation
of the binary character in the comics.
Like when Captain Marvel turned into binary.
Chris Claremont, who famous X-Men writer, obviously
was in the middle
of writing an uncanny X-Men storyline.
that's where Ms.. Marvel, she was named Ms..
Marvel at the time, turned into binary
for the first time,
he said that he created the binary form
for the character because they weren't allowed
to use the Phenix at the time,
and he wanted to use the Phenix in his X-Men storyline.
Ms.. Marvel Binary was meant to be kind of like
the stand in for that character then kind of became
a bigger thing for a little while in different comics
until they transitioned her back to the Ms..
Marvel role.
know because they're teasing all this X-Men stuff
and all the different Marvel
trailers,
everybody's hoping to see Rogue versus Captain Marvel.
They actually covered that storyline during X-Men,
the Animated series,
and it was an adaptation of the comic book version,
the story where Rogue basically got her powers
to fly by stealing Captain Marvel powers,
basically siphoning off the ability from her.
it wasn't her taking the ability to fly from her life.
She didn't take that power from her.
She just sucked.
So much of her power
that it made her powerful enough to fly.
my assumption is they're going to wait a while before
you actually see those characters meet on screen.
Like, it's not going to happen right away in
I don't know if we're going to see Rogue
in the first brand new X-Men movie
that Marvel is doing in the next couple of years.
they haven't completely confirmed who's
going to be on that initial roster of X-Men characters.
My guess is going to be pretty close
to the original classic roster.
kind of like their spin on X-Men
First Class, like doing the original team,
but doing it in a slightly different way
that none of the movies have done it before.
when Darvin is saying, this is just the beginning,
she's basically talking about
using this power across the entire universe
to the benefit of the Kree race.
The whole idea is that she's using that other Ms..
Marvel bangle,
which they're supposed to confirm are a combination
of quasars, quantum bands from the comics
and the Kree mega bands.
there were a bunch of theories about this when the Ms..
Marvel series came out
and I was doing videos for that a couple of years ago.
at the time, Marvel never really said anything
about it, obviously, now, because they were saving
a lot of that back story for the Marvel's movie, like,
this is what was going on.
But then the whole time you were all correct
Supposedly.
They're also supposed to explain
some of what's going on with Shang.
She's ten rings of power and that's supposed
to have some connection to the movie in some way.
I think it's supposed to be different
from their comic book origin.
Notice when she activates the bangle,
you see a bunch of those space portals open.
They're also supposed to explain how
all these space portals work and where they came from.
Like who started using them, how they got started.
James Gunn mostly use them for comedy during Guardians
of the Galaxy two, But are they part of the idea?
Like you see later in the trailer here
where she's opening these portals across space,
like normal portals that should only take you across
this single universe that they're in the 616 universe.
something about the way she's using the Bangles,
like there's some power interaction in it opens portals
through different universes, Like you see a crack here
in the other universes on the side
where Monica Rambeau
is talking about this other universe in,
it almost looks like the way she goes down the movie.
Like you see her just full of power,
like she keeps absorbing people's powers.
That's why she says that Captain Marvel's attacks
only make her stronger.
So the whole idea of the Captain Marvel
can't beat her by just punching her out.
It just makes her stronger.
and it looks like Monica Rambeau uses her power
to try and close the gate, like,
stop the incursion from happening.
And that might be how she winds up getting stuck
in the other universe at the end of the movie.
Because I actually think, you know, early theory,
they actually put part of the post-credits scene
of the movie in this trailer, and it's this scene here
where she's asking, how did we get here?
there's another person in a white uniform that seems
like she's also from Nick Fury's Saber Space station.
But I think this is in the other universe,
and I think this is meant to be Monica, Rambo's mother,
who became Captain Marvel in her universe,
just like in Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
Look at the hand here. Then look at Monica's face.
Would it not be her mother?
Like, why would she have that reaction?
And why would this person be wearing a cape
if they didn't have powers?
something about space caves always screams
that it's a special character.
Like it's not just some regular character,
like some regular tech walking around
I did a video about one of the last trailers
where they're actually teasing legit X-Men
like wait to see what comes next with highlighting
the X character.
Like X is an X-Men.
They also showed a version of this scene,
so I think we're going to see some X-Men
in this actual scene,
like it's part of the Post-Credits scene.
There's only supposed to be one for the movie.
I think the idea is that the universe
that Monica Rambeau winds up
getting stuck in is the universe where the X-Men exist.
and we'll just see one of those X-Men characters
in this Post-Credits scene.
It'll be sort of like a teaser for Deadpool
this scene of Nick Fury talking to someone, saying,
What are you prepared to do?
Is him talking to Monica Rambeau
they're couple jokes between them on the Saber Space
Station two because it seems like
she's been working for him on that space station
since the events of Wandavision like that was what
that Wandavision Post-Credits scene was teasing.
Someone wants to meet with you.
Someone who was a friend of your mother.
yeah, It's Nick Fury, way up top in the space station
When Captain Marvel says I'm invincible,
I think that's meant to dovetail
with the whole idea that DA Ben can just absorb
any power that she throws at her.
like, you might think that you're invincible,
but your power only makes me stronger,
To be fair, though,
we actually did see somebody kill Captain Marvel,
but was during what if season one
and it was the Infinity version of Ultron
that basically just pounded her so hard
that she never got up
also notice in this final fight scene
where they're all three of them fighting her.
She's also got both bangles on her hands.
so at some point she manages to steal Ms..
Marvel's bangle to giving her even more power.
that's probably how she's able to absorb
all of their power attacks.
during the last part of the trailer, they have
that Texas says be there for the moment.
That changes everything.
they show Monica Rambeau.
And what I think is that Post-Credits scene,
looking at a version of her mother, I think that's her
seeing the X-Men characters too.
Like that's the moment that they're teasing
based on all the previous terms, like the text,
the use the last time.
Be there for the moment that comes next.
As in X-Men
They show some of the scrolls in the background here.
They're actually going to be having that peace summit
that they mentioned at the end of the secret invasion.
They kind of tease that at the end of that,
they released a preview of the current
Skrull Emperor Droege that they talked
about during the Secret Invasion series.
He had like a separate colony on a separate planet
that wasn't part of Earth.
there was like, this whole separate sect of skrulls.
I think the idea is that
they're the ones that are still fighting the Kree.
and because the Chris girl war
has been going on for hundreds of years
they're trying to broker peace
between them during the events of this movie.
then they confirm all of our Thor theories
about the cameo in the movie.
Like the character that shows up,
I called a friend showing up on the back of her ship.
We see Valkyrie talking to them in her like the suit
that she wears when she's being normal king of Asgard.
Normally when she's sitting around day to day,
she doesn't wear her armor.
She wears an actual business suit.
And when she's telling Captain Marvel
she doesn't have to stand alone, that just meant to
highlight the idea that they're going to form
the new Avengers team in the next couple of years.
reminding you, because they use the Avengers theme song
at the end of this trailer
right after she says that There's a bunch of Easter
eggs and stuff that they reference in the trailer.
So if there's any.
You think you spotted that I didn't talk
about in this video or in previous videos,
just write it below in the comments.
a lot of theories out there, too,
about which X-Men that we might see during the movie.
So we'll see what they wind up actually doing.
like I said, my review video will be up on Wednesday
and then my post-credits
scene video should be up on Friday
after my Loki finale video.
There is a lot of really big stuff coming up
and really good news supposedly.
What if season two is going to be released
by the end of this year, or at least the first episode
will be released by the end of this year
because it'll be a weekly release.
click Here for my Marvels video
Post-Credits scene and Easter eggs.
I'll update the link as soon as I post those videos
later this week and click here
for my Loki Season 2 Episode 6 Finale Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!